[crowd cheering] Paris! Paris!
Paris! Paris! Paris! Paris! Paris!
I've given my whole life to everyone for so long.
It's just been really important
to me to keep this a secret.
Let’s wash our hands.
It's just the first time that something is just mine.
I’m gonna be a mom.
Literally no one knows.
My own family doesn't know.
Ever since I've been mic’d all I have done
is say the most terrible things. Oops!
If people found out, there would
be paparazzi all over Cedars.
I got you a surprise.
This is your
grandson, Phoenix.
Are you serious?
Yeah.
What is that?
Is that a... real?
Yes!
He’s so beautiful, so perfect.
My life is finally complete.
I’m so obsessed.
(Gasp!)
He’s peeing.
Oh no!
Oh! Hahahaha! That’s hot!
Have you talked to your mom about the book?
It's just not an easy subject.
Writing this book was one of the most
difficult experiences of my life.
Writing about things that I've never told anyone.
No!
I was just embarrassed and scared.
The fact that you couldn't come to us.
And we had to read about it online and in a book.
It's not right for us to just
read about it in the media.
What's your best advice?
It's not taking that job.
I don't want to leave him.
They’re this small for such a small window.
It's hard to say, “no.”
But you’re greedy.
Like, you’re very greedy.
No, I just like to work hard.
People who are trauma victims have a very
hard time happily bonding with their children.
[crowd cheering] Paris! Paris!
Paris! Paris! Paris!
Sliving.
Did you just fart on me?